[Applause]
my insurance Augustine on the drive
swatted away by Jackson junior rookie
from Michigan State and then a foul they
did the magic horror when he was on the
floor in the first half he really made
rapid improvement him throughout his
career at Tulane East the mountain
turnovers their Hornet score the most
points
Oladipo
did a much better job is playing
northern Saturdays Jared with a
rejection and
they able to really see him grow for an
entire year Bert blocked by Jairus shot
clock is off
Seldon speed dribble offensive foul he
not allowing the Grizzlies to get any
good clocks strong drive and that'll be
late jaren Jackson got the block denied
Fox and we're all tied at 71 for two
players
then it puts your entire team at
jeopardy of that one player doesn't come
through Brian Anderson with a Miss good
content by Jaron Jack's not gonna walk
your shot he's only got it on the ear
now he does have two tonight but Jamie
wanted to see the Grizzlies finish at
the rim
oh and eight rejected by jaren Jackson
speaking of block shots able to get back
does not commit a foul and high screen
around the horn it goes again bruiser
Sports pops in a big round that kid is
blocked by Jerry Jackson sensational
play by the rookie calmly on the
counter-attack seven for three living no
on the rebound
- Quinn cook these two teams will be
back here on December the 17th direct ko
blocked by Jaron that'll be blocked
number four giving up 14 points off the
walls turnovers that second fewest in
the NBA Millsap blocked by Jaron out of
islands that will stay with Denver but
jaren Jackson junior making an
impression crowd here at FedExForum
second block the thing which you don't
realize is how long in their feet so
after eight one Denver run Grisi scores
six straight
[Applause]
[Music]
Jackson doing it again Anderson away
from that rebound and then on the other
end let me keep showing you my link
sponsor fast-break opportunity in slow
seventies weary of and jaren stays down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
jaren get two seconds
Mitchell what Sharon Jackson jr. with
the rejection Burks smothered by Jaron
out of bounds that should be the fifth
block for him tonight there's another
knock away deletes a skip pass Fox Fox
got it back once he's out four plus and
I think he just did not respect these
other two young guys great block their
teeth forced to get so far over for his
second rebound deep position by Jordan
blocked by Jaron trying to deny the wing
passes the grizzy they get back to
getting those get back to Gitmo backdoor
cuts Gortat screen shot clock down to
five gallon re Hill Drive and bla out of
Darren Jackson junior blocks it out of
bounds
[Music]
Harris gets a screen drive he said by
jaren Jackson practically took it off
his hands Burke
covered it again
amazing week side deep it Trier
tightly to the floor to get a held ball
Ludi egg attacks
[Applause]
Bob on the floor Jared's got it fourth
quarter he has been fantastic in
one-on-one situations or in screen and
roll with a guard going downhill he's
been able to get a hand many is 7 in the
first half that's by as many as three
forced inside the arms hollis-jefferson
blocked by jaren Jackson Sixers out with
numbers and a beam Jared Jackson Wow
whooping Joel embiid did not think he
was gonna Kontest
going to the front of the rim you see
kind of slow down with the two Stefan
Jarrett knocked it away from Heretic
Simmons against Anderson but fake
blocked from behind by Jared
point defensively but and I think to
think a part of that partner is that
opposing teams nice move it great
defense though by Terran Zacks prison
haven't been forcing but here Gallinari
gets special with the behind the back
for is running the pick-and-roll also
executed very well partners moving
bodies in the ball extremely well and
then defensively contesting shots
Clippers look like a team at the end of
a four-game road trip McCallum 8 to
shoot layman goaltending 55 seconds
Turkish missed the dunk
jaren Jackson got a piece that play as
well again not lauded for his defense
does have two steals tonight capela
ahead of the field block by Jaron
great let's cover the distance teller
was wide open
jaren a trailing three bangle tiling his
three block by Lily we were trying to
get back defensively Amina blocked by
Jaron and he kept it in flames
wow that was exceptional he's gonna put
it on the deck he's gonna drive it and
bake it in 94 feet from the rookie you
see here the great health defense keeps
it in play the game will be in Memphis
on March the 5th grizz's back here on
April the 3rd McCollum blocked by Jaron
the song that gets guys up in the air
and that step-through move is become a
pattern one for Fox driving and jaren
Jackson said that's mine block apart he
just took it for Sheldon sets up Conley
corner three Banga Polly Stein single
coverage Shumpert no-look get Lee to
haul Jared with the rejection you see
here good block there by jaren Jackson
Grizz is just not able to come up with
the ball Jared Dudley five to shoot
heresy and Grizzlies force him inside
the yeah Jeremy with a block it's on a
bound it'll stay with the Nets we just
do seconds on the shot clock
51% from the floor Forbes early and
jaren Jackson with a rejection good
thick big thing for this grizzly team is
they've done a good job but off the
Richardson
Winslow's retying his shooter Tyler
Johnson walked by Jaron Olynyk
and we get the offensive foul
olynyk heart walk by Jackson put Abijah
Michael Greene
seven to shoot rivers got the step
Terran with the rejection great help
defense there by Darren but then the
misfire led show good contest by a
gerund ended up on the seat of his pants
as looking for a foul ball got none look
ahead to Horford some Idaho and block by
Jaron and Gasol off the rebound and here
come the Grizzlies Conley on the attack
against Irving it's up it's in at a foul
on Kyrie Irving great human being
John was Sharon says to randall not in
our house half is one side screen and
rolls we'll even mid screen arose we
always talk about being in bodies
everywhere no whistle Grizzlies have it
Kyle
[Music]
Jochen offensive rebounds five dishes
handling the basketball making things
happen here a nice reaction by gerunds
accent junior to come up with that
blocking in no Derrick Rose for
Minnesota tonight towns rechecked at Oh
Jaron goes down hard
Minnesota chance for their first lead of
the game Wiggins
towns picks it up two big blocks by the
Grizzlies bound by Holliday Jackson on
the attack good defense by Conley the
Jackson got it back then deflected Davis
gets it back in that sequence with his
third assist but this third I was just
gerrans second shot of the game to be
successful in that first has good block
here by oh oh and Jaron goes down hard
here I have arrived it's caught on the
pump fake but Jaron there's they would
have beat it for the help you can see
that late you find those pass you get
the scratches any hasn't really been
clear they used to thanks Elvis you see
the beam go inside might have gotten
foul what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content